during the break Gary I caught him on
zoom' I came back from the bathroom and
he's on zoom' telling the guys I don't
know if I could ever go back to New York
and this and I'm like Brian you're going
back I'm not going back but you are well
he's not going back until you go back no
he's going back to test out the studio
before I go back I'll see if he gets
sick he's like the canary in the coal
mine are you kidding listen I don't know
a [ __ ] thing and I don't see us back
in New York before the end of this year
at the earliest and some guys are like
yeah we'll probably come back after
Labor Day I'll go based on what you know
whatever the date is that somebody says
you can go back how it's gonna go six
months past that well look I could
envision after Labor Day you going back
Gary and I really can and then I'm going
to do the show from here Gary I'll be in
Manhattan and we'll see what happens to
him watch it like elaborate yeah I mean
he'll go
he'll commute and he can produce from
there and then like three months later
maybe I'll show up okay
no but but but seriously at some point
Gary needs to go back to work
someone's got to go in first I love it
to work when I'm convinced it is
perfectly safe to be back at well that's
not your decision I'll decide when it's
safe for you to go
[Laughter]
it's not safe right now but soon it will
be and you'll be back all right I have a
question for you for me I need advice we
have friends who are talking about
coming to visit me in the summer
[Laughter]
okay so what's what's the question my
question is how do I politely tell them
oh hell no say what do you got did you
guys happen to look in the newspaper
recently or look online at the news
listen I don't know who these people are
but you got to raise up your level of
friends I mean just lock the door
they'll figure it out